[Musik]
sarah leidet unter den folgen einer
nasen-op zum einen hat er mir viel zu
viel haut entfernt von der nase
besonders von der nasenspitze
das ist manchmal führt auch christina
hat sich auf die fünf sterne bewertungen
dieses hier oben verlassen
dabei hat der arzt im internet viele
gute bewertungen
wie kann das sein wir recherchieren und
finden firmen die ihr geld mit gekauften
bewertungen verdienen wie die
bewertungsplattform goldstar marketing
an einem geheimen ort treffen wir einen
mitarbeiter
er spielt uns interne dokumente zu unser
arzt ist kein einzelfall viele ärzte
pimpen
mit top bewerten wir haben wirklich
massiv viele ärzte und zahnärzte kunden
wir sind auf der spur eines
internationalen netzwerks das sich
geschickt der justiz
und sie bleiben draußen und damit basta
aus
[Musik]
sarah hat ein problem mit ihrer nase und
fängt an zu suchen
[Musik]
das ärzteportal jameda empfiehlt ihr
einen arzt mit besten bewertungen
ich bin einfach nur glücklich
sehr nette und sehr kompetenter arzt
meine tochter ist nach ihrer nasen op
noch hübscher geworden
die positiven bewertungen haben bei mir
ein gutes gefühl ausgelöst also auf
jeden fall dass ich dort bestimmt gut
aufgehoben sein werde und dass ich nach
hat die nase haben werdet die ich mir
schon immer gewünscht habe es gibt ein
paar studien die besagen dass ungefähr
80 prozent der menschen die nach solchen
bewertungen lesen diese auch für wahr
halten noch monate nach der operation
hat sarah probleme dicken haben ihre
nase fühlt sich taub an sarah macht den
plastischen chirurgen schwere vorwürfe
also zum einen hat er mir viel zu viel
haut entfernt von der nase besonders an
der nasenspitze und auch wenn ich
morgens aufstehe ich meine nase immer
sehr angeschwollen und verfällt man
kennt das ja wenn man schnupfen hat weiß
man erst zu schätzen wie es ist durch
die nase zu atmen
sarah ist nicht die einzige christina
war beim selben arzt für eine brust op
ihr mussten die brüste schließlich ganz
entfernt werden und das war nicht das
einzige
die wird stich dieses vom skalpell des
ansetzen wo man einfach merkt du wirst
hand aufgeschnitten realisiert es aber
doch irgendwie nicht ganz weil der
schmerz so intensiv ist dass du einfach
nur denkst hoffen ich habe das jetzt und
ich habe es ihnen gesagt allerdings hat
er gemeint ich könnte keine schmerzen
haben ich würde simulieren und für mich
war das wie so ein schlag ins gesicht
wenn der arzt selber da steht und im
endeffekt dir sagt dass du das zugleich
in dem moment einfach mist erzählst aber
ich denke und ich spüre hier sagt es
kann nicht sein
sarah und christina sind nicht alleine
mit ihrer erfahrung dutzende
patientinnen haben dem plastischen
chirurgen angezeigt viele haben
schmerzen leiden psychisch sind
entstellt
und trotzdem hat genau dieser arzt
rezensionen vom feinsten kann das
stimmen oder werden bewertungen
manipuliert vielleicht sogar gekauft das
wollen wir wissen und googeln erstmal
erste überraschung es gibt viele treffer
die anbieter haben namen wie pfister
marketing bewertungen kaufen oder
goldstar marketing bewertungen sind die
wichtigste währung im internet bei
goslar marketing im angebot bewertungen
für google amazon und sonstige
plattformen wie jameda firmen wie
goldstar sind schwer zu greifen
alles läuft virtuell ab unsere an fragen
bleiben unbeantwortet
dann meldet sich doch jemand aber nicht
offiziell ein gold damit arbeiter lehrt
uns zu einem treffen ein an einem
geheimen ort denn er will auspacken über
millionenfache lügen im internet und das
große geschäft
es ist mittlerweile fast alles gefälscht
und gefegt man kann da leider keinen
wert darauf geben seines produkt
rezensionen sei es eine meinung über
einen arzt über eine fahrschule über
anwälte autohändler sind auch sehr große
kunden
sie kaufen für mobile de oder autoscout
und wie läuft die akquise berufen firmen
an und erklären ihnen dann wir sind von
der firma goldstar marketing wir machen
bewerbungskampagne und übernehmen die
arbeit ihrer zufriedenen kunden
und was versprechen sie denen alles mehr
kunden natürlich und vor allem mehr
umsatz für seine behauptungen hat der
informant handfeste beweise
er gibt uns hoch brisante unterlagen aus
dem innenleben von golfstar marketing
rechnungen zahlungsbelege e-mail-verkehr
tausende dokumente die belegen positive
bewertungen bei google amazon und
anderen portalen werden zu hunderten zu
tausenden gekauft rechtsanwälte ärzte
handwerker sogar stadtwerke machen mit
und wir stoßen auf einen alten bekannten
dem plastischen chirurgen er bestellte
100 google bewertungen für 879 euro
wir wollen den arzt mit unserer
recherche persönlich konfrontieren
denn auf unsere schriftlichen fragen hat
er nicht reagiert wir suchen ihn in
seiner praxis auf doch die ist
verschlossen wie erfahren die behörden
haben ihnen die approbation entzogen
wir gehen zu seiner privatadresse und
drehen mit versteckter kamera
also ich habe nie irgendwelche
bewertungen gekauft meine bewertung sind
alle echt
aber ich habe hier eine bestellung über
google bewertungen die müsste ja von
ihnen seien
es kann sein dass man eine internet
betreut zum zeitpunkt als die hetze
gegen mich los ging gesagt haben okay
jetzt müssen wir mal gucken dass wir da
ein bisschen luft rein kriegen
den vorwurf er habe operationen
verpfuscht weiß der arzt vehement zurück
unser gold star informant erinnert sich
an dem plastischen chirurgie hat sehr
viele bewertungen gekauft zu seine
praxis den genauen umfang weiß ich nicht
nur fünf sterne bewertungen so dass er
natürlich als super harz sind gestellt
wird aber er ist nicht der einzige wir
haben wirklich massiv viele ärzte und
zahnärzte als kunden positive
bewertungen bei google msn und auf
anderen portalen werden zu tausenden
gekauft das belegen die dokumente
unseres whistleblowers wir wollen den
chef des bewertungsportals kolster
marketing damit konfrontieren denn
gekaufte bewertungen posten das ist
nicht strafbar
allerdings könnte ein verstoß gegen die
regeln des fairen wettbewerbs vorliegen
nach langer suche finden wir den chef
norbert weber vor seiner villa im
grunewald
wir sind vom zdf hatten ihnen fragen
geschickt wir wollen wir keine aufnahmen
haben
haben sie unsere fragen bekommen ja
haben wir aber wir antworten da nicht
drauf und sie bleiben draußen und damit
basta aus norbert weber schweigt über
sein geschäftsmodell unser informant der
golfstar mitarbeiter hat antworten das
geschäft mit den bewertungen ist das
lukrativ ich würde schätzen er verdient
damit zwischen 3 und 5 millionen euro im
jahr
damit wird er definitiv reich christina
schreibt eine negative bewertung von
jameda wurde sie nie veröffentlicht
später bemerkte sie auch andere äußerten
kritik
leider enttäuschend ergebnis ist eine
katastrophe
unfassbar schlechte arzt er hat mich
verunstaltet aber diese bewertungen
wurden schnell wieder gelöscht
jameda sagt es fehlten die beweise nach
unseren recherchen gibt es viele ärzte
die jameda bewertungen kaufen
das unternehmen meint dazu einen 100
prozentigen schutz vor kriminellen
missbrauch kann aber leider kein system
bietet jameda ist mit seinen massnahmen
gegen fake bewertungen aber seit langem
vorreiter wenn jetzt zwei drei schlechte
werden gewesen hätte hätte wenigstens
einen kleinen zweifel gehabt an dem
ganzen und hätte mir vielleicht fünf mal
überlegt ob ich da hingehen oder mir
vielleicht sogar nichts vormachen
eingeholt da ich auch eine einzelwertung
gelesen habe war ich der meinung der
axis tipper top und an dingen kann ich
gehen und der kann ich blind vertrauen
der fall des plastischen chirurgen
beschäftigt jetzt auch die justiz gegen
den arzt wird wegen mehrfacher schwerer
körperverletzung ermittelt der arzt
hingegen klagt gegen den entzug seiner
approbation in diesem prozess
und er streitet alle vorwürfe ab doch
zahlreiche patientinnen wollen
schmerzensgeld falsche bewertungen kann
man vielleicht noch löschen
eine verpfuschte nase nicht worauf
achtest du wenn du einen arzt suchst
schreibt es uns in die kommentare